I I feel like in relationships where the  man is already saying listen this is  what it is like for example Angie Tate  how he talks about how he would just  seep around with women regardless of  whether you like it or not if you want  it stay if you don't leave in that  situation you've given her an ultimatum  she's made the choice however if we are  going into a monogamous relationship and  then you step out of the relationship to  Chi that is disrespect do you feel like  you kind of make the choice though if  you pick that type of guy but come on we  know which guys are gonna cheat we know  come on like we we know what you guys  might cheat and if you pick them it's  like having said that